[Music]
dawson is in virginia i'm a 19 year old
college student currently in my junior
year was wondering if i should invest in
and build an airbnb business with my
brother
the only debt i have is three thousand
dollars in student loans i have thirty
thousand dollars in stocks and eight
thousand dollars in savings we have a
lot of knowledge in this business
because my brother already owns one
uh we plan on paying cash for it
and i'd save until i had the amount for
my half would it be a good idea to go in
50 50 with my brother on a property it
would cost
110k um
if you're debt free and you have an
emergency fund in place and you pay cash
for it
it's fine
the downside is this
there's several downsides um
beware of anything
when you've done it once and you call
yourself an expert
uh your brother has one of these and
airbnb
if airbnb is the only way the property
purchase makes sense don't buy it
it needs to also make sense in a
traditional rental if airbnb goes away
because there's a lot of municipalities
coming down on them and shutting them
down in different areas there's a lot of
problems with it the other thing is that
this is the highest hassle
highest possible hassle
rental that you can have
you're basically running a freaking
hotel
and it's a lot of work
and a lot of problems
and so the numbers that you see this
thing making on the stage
um i mean on the page on the pro forma
of this
uh are not going to happen
it's going to be less than that and you
have not really anticipated the level of
work and if you let this stupid property
distract you from getting your degree
then don't do it at all
the second downside
other than that in this situation
is that you are now in a partnership
with your brother you are single i don't
know if he is
um and it may work well for a few years
and then you may need to sell out of it
because it's probably not something
you're going to own together when you're
80.
and so you need a detailed
written
partnership agreement that states what
happens
to this property or what happens in the
event one of you wants out
in the event that
one of you can't pay for their half or
don't can't do their part of their half
of the work
or the bills
uh in the event that one of you goes
down the toilet and becomes a drug
addict
or becomes disabled
or dies
or gets divorced and now you end up
owning a airbnb with his ex-wife
because the judge awards her his half
yeah that sounds like fun
not
these are the unanticipated things that
happen when you go into a partnership
even with your own brother
and so i'm not a big fan of that my
preference would be that you save up
your own money and you go by your own
after you get out of college
and you pay cash for it
uh it sounds like you've got the ability
to put some money together and that's
probably the direction i would go
also you said you had um
uh let me get my numbers right here you
have three thousand dollars in debt
thirty thousand in stocks and eight
thousand dollars in savings you should
write a check today and pay off your
debt
there's no reason for you to carry that
debt with that much money sitting around
so let's pile up the rest the cash make
sure you graduate from college and pay
cash for your own airbnb would be my
preference that's what i would rather
you do
um rather than jumping ahead here
it it's just all that glitters is not
gold
and this there's a lot more to this a
lot more work than i i sense that you
realize may be wrong but that's my sense
on